good morning Millennials we are so
excited to be sitting down with someone
who we've spoken about 1 million times
on this show we absolutely love her and
when her name came across our desk we
were strict for the core tik-tok queen
Lauren gray hi Lauren how are you thank
you for being having me you are so cute
we are so excited like we have been
following you for so long you are 45
million strong on tick-tock something
like that it's crazy you've been you've
been in it for a while I used to follow
you on musically and things are just
happening there's so much going on you
just released a new song Kate can you
tell us a little bit about that
yeah so it's my first single that I
released in a while I took a little
break and then because I really wanted
to work on you know nailing down my
sounds and putting out something that I
was proud of so I finally got to that
point after like I don't even know how
long eight or nine months but yeah don't
know that's cool what's it like to
release a song during quarantine um
honestly I feel like because I'm not
your like traditional artist it wasn't
that different than what I typically do
obviously there's no going out and doing
promo but that's the only difference
really I haven't really toured yet so
that hasn't really made a difference
because I've been waiting to get a
bigger body of music before I do
anything so yeah for me it was just not
that different yeah but your um your
music video was different cuz you've
recorded it at home and you had some of
your favorite some of my favorite tick
tock stars in there but I imagine that
wasn't that different for you because
you have a lot of YouTube experience so
was putting together that music video
kind of just like filming a YouTube
video yeah so they send me a shot list
and I used I filmed on my phone because
my camera is actually not my phone has
better quality than my camera is the
same thing yeah it's like just like
filmed it on my phone and it was it was
it took four days it was kind of it was
kind of difficult because you have to do
so many takes of the same thing in
different locations and obviously I had
to set up my own lighting and I was
making tripods out of like cardboard
boxes but it worked and it turned out
you know better than I could have hoped
for so I'm glad
again the song is so good hmm we love
your music your song anti-everything
like is the anthem of our life we had
the lost kings on our show like probably
a year ago now and they were just so fun
we're talking about you and it was it
was a highlight yeah I love that song I
always when I listen to it now I I feel
like I sound so young because I recorded
it years ago but I still love it I was
playing in the cardioid day oh wait just
not that song there's when I think about
it there's so many similarities between
that song and the one from Taylor
Swift's lover album
I think it's Cornelia Street the way it
starts like Claud you were the one who
said that oh yeah did you ever notice
that someone pointed it out and was like
oh you copy Taylor Swift I was like no I
think but speaking of we got so many
questions for you and probably like the
number one thing I wanted to ask you was
your experience um filming the music
video for the man with Taylor Swift you
played a little cute little ball girl on
a tennis court and we just need I need
every single detail from the moment you
woke up to the moment you went to sleep
like what was that like yeah so I got up
I here's where I bought myself like I
bought myself a nicer car but I've been
driving like my 2014 Kia for awhile and
I was super insecure driving next I was
like oh my god I'm driving myself to
this music video set that's like two
hours away and and I'm like I don't know
who's gonna be here because I didn't
know what it was gonna be because a lot
of times with big artists they don't
really tell you what's what's happening
beforehand just to keep everything you
know top secret whatever and then
eventually they told me and I was
waiting around in a lot of green rooms
because you know how it goes and I was
really nervous and then I got to the set
and Taylor came out but I didn't know it
was her because she had the full
prosthetics on and there was another guy
who was like a stunt double who was also
on set that looked exactly like her with
prosthetics and you couldn't really tell
them apart unless you were like talking
so she started talking she was like oh I
just like thank you so much like I know
from Pennsylvania like we're from the
same area and all this nothing because
she is she went to school it literally
down the street from my house so then I
realized it was him when she started
talking I talked her for a while she's
really cool and that was really really
refreshing because you know people say
you're nuts you've never supposed to
meet your idols and I was so so nervous
because she's like my number one female
pop star i watch her reputation too
we're on Netflix and I cry every time
she I would like arias Lee I'm one of
those people that I get like proud of
someone that I don't even know like I'm
so proud of her so I got turned up
talking about it but like I just get so
proud of other people especially you
know coming from nothing and making
something of yourself is you know
something really special so I didn't
really tell I was like yeah yeah then
she ended up we shot the scene and it
was really cool to watch her do her
thing the way that she was she did
direct that video like when she says she
directed it she was calling the shots
and it was really inspiring to see
someone you know take control like that
and she was just being absolutely crazy
it was really interesting and fun to
watch and then I left then I drove home
and then so crazy I called everyone by
everyone I mean my parents I was allowed
to tell anyone that's honestly just such
goals like congratulations I feel the
same way about Taylor but can we
backtrack for a minute because you're
huge on tik-tok but you've kind of were
one of the early adapters on the
platform do you be in popularity when it
was still musically but obviously things
have changed so much in the last year I
would love to hear your take on what you
think about the whole rebrand do you
like the new different types of content
do you miss musically how do you how is
your content shifted what are your
thoughts yeah I feel like you know
platforms are always evolving and
there's always gonna be something new
obviously the ribbon was a little bit
difficult to get used to at first it was
really out of nowhere like I didn't
expect it to change completely as a
platform and I actually
took like a six month break I didn't
even know what it was because it went
through this transitional period but no
one really knew what to post on it um
anyways before it kind of got cool and
there was memes but because musically
and no hate so like what I was doing but
it wasn't cool like I saw much heat for
even doing it because it was cringing I
was this and was that but then now it's
like the coolest thing ever and everyone
wants to be take talk famous so it was a
little bit hard to get used to but I
feel like I've always been pretty good
at adapting to things and I have
obviously I still keep a little bit of
what I was you know there's that string
of I've always been the same just
adopting you know yeah yeah well it's
just so fascinating to watch your
community grow and to watch your numbers
grow there's so many in like politics
now on tick-tock and we got so many
questions for you and I'm sure you get
this all the time but what are your kind
of best practices when it comes to
people who want to gain traction what
kind of content do you think does best
of course everyone has different
communities but what are some tips of
the trade that you could give to our
viewers yeah I usually just kind of see
what's trending what sounds are trending
and I'll do my own take on that or
whatever trend is happening mixed in
with content obviously that I come up
with myself sometimes it just depends
but I think the biggest key to gaining
traction is just consistency and
understanding that the first video that
you post might not be the one that goes
viral but eventually you know the more
you post eventually things will catch on
and audiences will grow appreciate and
you've gotten so big on tick tock and of
course there are many many perks of that
like filming the Taylor Swift's music
video but a lot of people might not
recognize some of the challenges that
come with that and I'm sure a lot of
that has to do with negativity we
experienced our fair share how do you're
so young like how do you deal with that
how do you not let it affect your mental
health I feel like I because I've been
doing it for so long I acquired a thick
skin really early I made my mistakes
when I was 13 14 and then after that I
kind of gotten this for
tene where I kind of separated myself
from the things that people have to say
and I was just talking about this the
other day like I have separated online
from myself as a person which I'm still
myself online but my self-worth is
detached from that aspect so I feel like
it's really important not to you know
attach ego and self-worth and all those
kinds of things to the Internet and
that's something that I learned over
time obviously but yeah it was hard at
first of course and I was really young
when I started everything so it was
really confusing but the older I've
gotten the more that I'm able to
disassociate those two things and a lot
of the times people just say things on
the internet because they're insecure
and I know everyone says that but I was
talking to this other girl who was like
kind of a new influencer and I was
trying to tell her you know you have the
upper hand hey what you have and that's
just they just hate to see other people
doing well and that's something that I
recognized over time but that's kind of
what helps with that that's such a
mature point of view like it takes so
many people so many years and sometimes
people need would never even get to that
other side of being able to develop that
thick skin or like just disassociate
what's going on online from real life
because they are so different and you
can literally just turn your phone off
and all that noise doesn't exist anymore
and so I think that's a really great
approach that you have um and it's
really inspiring yeah and I feel like a
lot of people can look up to in a lotta
ways and that's what I really like about
tik-tok is the people who we've started
to idolize like you and you know people
with huge followings Charlie you guys
are really just regular girls and you
really relate to a lot of your audience
in a very responsible way so I commend
you for being really an excellent role
model for young people all over the
world Thanks yeah I try I mean I feel
like that's really the only way to the
only way to do it you know you can't
really get too far being problematic and
relying on
people paying attention to that to get
ahead because you're not really you're
not what's the word I'm looking for it
it's not something that's sustainable
and you're not really a building a real
fan base you're building people who
watch when here's exciting bad happens
yeah and I learned that also really
quickly but I feel like the best thing
to do because the Internet is such a
negative place sometimes is to be a
positive outlet for people to turn to
and it's very few and far between
because you don't find a lot of people
on the internet who would genuinely want
to be good people everyone's just
looking to get ahead and those people
don't last Wow very well said well thank
you for stopping by congratulations on
your single can you tell people where to
follow you where can they listen to your
music sure my Instagram is Lauren my
tick-tocks Lauren gray my Twitter's I am
I think my snapchats Lauren and then my
song cake is on Spotify Apple music
Dexter I've done all the liners so I
know all of them they're on everything
it's it's everywhere ease into it it's
so good and the videos on YouTube and
it's so cute and you did such a great
job thank you so much for being here and
congratulations on your new song and all
your success and thank you guys for
listening to the morning toast we'll see
you tomorrow